[Music]
Heavenly Father we want to thank you for
this day of life my heart is all full of
joy for these women right here lord
please make sure that Lisa don't get an
STD and that nobody has kidney failures
we finna get messed up and let me get
pregnant by somebody rich that's our
last Amy we haven't hung in five years I
miss you guys
we need a girls trip that's my car
not anymore baby what if I just without
my titties you know okay a - I'll take a
to D for a bike ride you sure you want
to get turned this weekend with your
girls I say this out of love preach girl
mmm if you are going to come along with
us please refrain from saying things
like preach or go girl or any other
colloquialisms that you may have looked
up on urban dictionary girl bath let go
this weekend is about us we deserve this
so let's go
I have to pee look the line is short
over there there's a long line in the
bathroom here just go
[Music]
[Music]
hell no I've known about this for a few
months now but that's in the past
especially was taken last night we need
to talk clearly nothing you need to say
to her that you can't say in front of us
take my stun gun just had him in a ball
today is the last day that we will ever
be this young I've not had this much fun
in so long
wait I got what you need right here this
is 200 year old absence you drink too
much of it it's gonna hair you
hallucinate you coming to get me got
something I'm Trixie you know I got some
bomb-ass push if you want to take the
hit where did you hide way to spend
outside you know what that can cause a
lot of infection girl you can't get no
infection in your booty ho if the booty
up
[Music]
so clean
[Music]